joe madden is on the phone right now
thrilled to have the manager of the
angels calling in today because he's an
old friend of mine and
joe i haven't seen you since we ha ha
since the angels won the world series in
2002 how are you thanks for taking the
time
let's do it again right no kidding uh
you're welcome and it's great to hear
you again
i know it's great to be with you how
many years is this now in all with the
angels are we at 32 33
um listen i i left i think it was
31. so this is my
second floor like 3233 something like
that i signed in
75 without a boulder colorado and then i
started in 76
went through 2005 left and came back
last year so
this is home it feels like home it's
it's really strange you go to these
different spots and you come back put
the uniform on it's like you never left
and when you talk to some of your
players about your experience because
you've got
a couple other guys you've got jose
molina who
was benji's little brother right and a
couple pitching coaches too who were
with you for that 2002 run
how do you get your guys now who are so
far removed from that to realize that
you've got
all these guys that won a title for the
angels right there in front of them
yeah they're aware i mean our guys are
aware of everything these days
um it's just them they regardless of the
the coaches have been there or not it's
just a matter of competency and how they
interact with the group and
right now i'm here to tell you uh of
course we were missing some really key
components but
we walk in our locker room i don't know
if i've been in a better one
i've been to some really good ones
obviously in chicago and tampa bay
loved all those guys too but this thing
here right now the way we're all coming
together
it's a real like i don't know third
fourth month now to really create the
culture last year
um you know that that mini season a lot
of people refer to it as the 2020 season
it was just an abbreviated form of that
they're really time to to get your
program out there and accept the culture
this group is
this group is doing that for the angels
for for this year and years to come
and i really enjoy going to work every
day with these guys
angels manager joe madden joins us here
on the rich eisen show suzy schuster in
for
rich it's got to be because of show hey
otani my favorite baseball player i need
to know what it is like for you
managing this sensation
actually it's easy um he's uh he takes
care of everything
he he knows what he wants he knows how
to
to work about to get his work done to
get what he wants
he is an incredible baseball athlete
where he's able to do
things on the fly he'll create stuff on
a nightly basis whether it's on the
mound
at the plate you saw him last night he
was surely going to try to bunk but then
he said no
and then he then he smokes a pitch he's
he's just a really good baseball player
with a high baseball intellect
i just we communicate every day between
me him and epay as translator and we
talk
about elongated conversations but uh
find out what he's up to how he's
feeling what he thinks he can do on a
particular day
and we will with that from there and and
i think that's a part of the success
this year is how simple we've kept it
it's a real simple conversation daily
and that sets up the next day and
he's just a unique talent obviously
that's an understatement but
it's it's all on him man it's how he he
makes it really easy to work with
what's his interaction like with all the
other players then with that
language barrier i'd say everybody talks
about the language barrier it's really
not there he's trying real hard
and he's able to communicate in english
and just like me when i try to
communicate in spanish with my guys that
i throw my two years in high school two
years of college out there
and and they understand enough and i
keep trying to learn more and that's
what he's doing
um they giggle he giggles easily he's uh
compared to last year this year when
lashes stone-faced all the time and
a little bit too serious this year's the
exact opposite
and the players and and him they they
interact so well
um so the sentence there the
uh the interest in learning the english
language is absolutely there
and so the the guys they they get along
greatly and he is a big part of
the reason why obviously not just on the
field but the clubhouse how he handles
all this really makes it easy
i know how incredibly level-headed you
are but do you ever sit back and think
about
just how lucky you are to be where you
are right now to manage
this incredibly unique talent
listen i'm grateful for a lot of things
i um
i do believe i've earned the right to be
here over a period of time and that's
really important to me
as opposed to a job him to me
for whatever reason i came up through
the minor leagues i think that's the
right way to do it i've been a scout
i think that's the right way to do it
i've learned from some of the best that
have ever done this
and then they get uh opportunities in
different cities and then they get this
chance right here
and i do believe my ability to interact
with shohei
is because of what i've learned over the
course of the years from a lot of great
coaches and managers um experience
feel being the gift of experience i've
been able to go through all of this
and i get here it's not just him i mean
how about you know michael trump's
pretty good too and
we're going to get anthony back jared
walsh is really ascended
and then while these guys have been
injured look what's happening on the
field with a lot of guys that have not
had opportunity they're doing really
well
uh but i am i am very grateful i'm still
very fortunate
uh but from my perspective it's really
important to me that i think that i've
earned it
that is true you brought up your
three-time al mvp when is mike trout
coming back
um i don't know um i talked to him
yesterday soon
a little bit better actually i was going
through some tests again
today that will indicate how well this
is
uh healed you know a lot of it is just
things that he's feeling
and you know you've been in a situation
where you've been injured especially in
your leg
you go ahead and try to test it and
you're always in the back of your mind
concerned about
pushing that little bit extra it causes
that little bit of pain to come and
you really don't want to re-injure it so
you got to fight through those mental
adhesions and that's what he's doing
so with the test today hopefully in
continued support from the doctor
will be able to move it along a little
bit more what are your thoughts on
moving him to a corner taking him out of
center field to kind of limit that
motion yeah i've already had that
conversation with him and he thinks that
when he comes back it's not going to be
an issue
but we'll see um you got to get out
there you got to start playing again
and he'll let me know we have a really
say that's the thing about michael i
said it to i think one of our coaches
just in the bench i mean i don't care if
this guy's a baseball player and i don't
care what he's done this
this guy's likable you just have to like
my drought
conversationally it's every day on the
bench who mostly up to me
when the game begins we just talk about
where he's at it's an
easy conversation talking about a
superstar
of superstars and he is this guy um so
uh we'll see we'll see he'll be honest
with me how he's feeling
and we'll make that determination
joe baden on the phone with us i know
you've got a game tonight so i'll let
you go in a couple of minutes here on
the rich eisen show
shohei can he be the mvp
even if you're not one of the top teams
in baseball chris brockman of course
red sox apologist know made some other
comments about whether or not he thinks
joe hey otani could be the mvp
right chris well i just think there's a
difference between valuable and
outstanding with all due respect to what
he's doing
it's tremendous we've obviously never
seen it before in a hundred years but
you know 500 team against a team that's
25 games over 500 i'm just saying
you know there's a difference in my
opinion yeah the other team probably has
a more balanced team possibly they
they possibly have a lockdown bullpen uh
they possibly have kept all their
players healthy all year and you can't
control any of that
of course um that's all semantics to me
um
for me if you're in the dog out or in
the clubhouse with this fella on a daily
basis
and you get to watch this um it's the
most valuable player in baseball
um i i would argue that with anybody a
combination of hitting and pitching at
the level that he does and not just
hitting i was like
i was 37th last night with 81 rbis
already
and the game that he pitched the other
day against colorado
once again nobody does that nobody's
done that ever
ever so at what point would you then
consider him for the award
if it's just contingent upon the rest of
the group i mean i remember alex
rodriguez
winning a mvp with texas right when they
were in last place i believe
and i agree with 100 i never at that
point
i said my god i mean i saw him when he
was a baby uh and instructionally with
the mariners uh
in peoria um arizona i think my god i
mean i've never seen anybody go to this
left that well
and then he just kills it in texas and
then wins the mvp and he deserved it so
i think it's all semantic secrets which
your philosophy which you believe would
religion do you believe in
and then you you can argue that point
but i think there's there's no question
he is the mvp for me are you surprised
what he's been able to do
on the mound just enable to keep that
keep that focused
not you know by while still playing
every day in the outfield
uh as a dh but that's what i'm talking
about it's what he's doing is so
unnatural
right um it's and not only that just
think about this
too he plays the day after he pitches
now you ask anybody that pitches
i think i'll go back to my high school
base my whole right side of my body
was sore the next i mean like short
right and and
you know this is his last picture of the
day i think was 99 or 100 miles
100 miles per hour in the seventh inning
yeah right and so
that what that requires physically
coordination
and just pure strength is is really
unheard of
it is and and then play the next day and
play well the next day and want to steal
faces the next day and looking for the
green light all the time
um it's just
you'll see you watch a lilly game you
watch the best player on the field
wow that kid's really good he's the best
player in the field in a major league
game
every night he plays so that's that's
what i'm saying it's
um it's different i don't know the next
time you're gonna see this
um it's not lost on me at all obviously
you're hearing what i'm saying right now
but you got to be with it every day to
really appreciate the full flavor
yeah the and the mental focus too
because obviously
he's studying his at bats to get better
in that aspect and then he's also has to
study himself on the mount to get better
in that regard too it's just kind of
remarkable
he's an artist he's always creating he
is i've often thought that
i had this uh this line of artwork a
couple years ago putting the
art back into the game i had the mona
lisa as the center piece
she has eye eye black on she's got
batting gloves on and
um this guy is an artist i'm telling you
because we can give him
all the uh discount reports that we have
but when he gets to the mount especially
he is going to create based on what he's
seeing and what he's feeling
and not everybody not hardly anybody can
do that let me put it that way hardly
anybody can do what he can do
nightly by just all of a sudden uh
throwing out this cutter because the
slider's not working they're vice versa
i can't find my split in the first two
innings but he'll drop it on you'll be
six and it'll be outstanding uh my
fastball command's not working here in
the second
let me just go to all breaking pitches
he's got great feel for what he does
and and again that's uh you gotta watch
it you gotta see it nightly uh
maddie wiser pitching coach has been
concerned on different occasions and
they say listen
just leave him alone and just watch what
he's doing because it's unexplainable
he has skill that nobody else has you
have to wonder
how does he keep it up how does he keep
up the
energy it's incredible yeah you're right
and that's what i'm saying
because he plays uh when he's not
pitching
and i know it's a dh and i know he's not
necessarily standing on his feet but
he exerts a lot of energy and then it's
the work that he does to stay sharp
whether it's in the cage he doesn't hit
on the field which i love it
it's one of the most overrated things we
do in our game everybody wants to see
this extra work on the field all the
time
especially this time of year i think
that it contributes to us getting better
there's always a point of diminishing
return set again and i don't like when
guys get arm weary
he does that he does details very
lightly in between starts it's not this
elongated uh it's like when you go to
the practice dean of golf
you know you hit a couple good shots you
just keep swinging to the swing poorly
and then you stay there another half
hour to try to swing better again he
knows what he's feeling and he knows
when he needs
extra this or that and then he does but
he handles it he cannot handle it better
i'm telling you cannot handle
this whole thing better and i love
working with him
in regards to all this and believe me
i'm just i'm falling asleep
from a sheer love of the game
perspective joe joe madden from the los
angeles angels here on the rich eisen
show
from a sheer love of the game you like
watching him
hitting or pitching oh
i really enjoyed the f-bats and right
now
it mentioned that last night so unusual
they're going to come after him hard
every time obviously
it's so unusual to see a hitter when he
gets a strike get this a swing
almost every time meaning that it's
full-fledged it is
the back wall of the ballpark swing
i mean hit this ball as hard as i
possibly can there's there's not this
check swing involvement
um it's incredible it's his ability to
get off his best wing on a
on a pitch that he likes and then beyond
that he's taking his walks
he's able to shut it down when it's not
a good pitch and that's what i'm saying
stay out of his way don't get in his
head don't give him any thoughts right
now let him just play
he's playing baseball this was that
everybody should seek
um all of us that overthink things at
times
he is you really need to appreciate what
he's doing and how he's doing it because
that's the way it should be done pure
joy for the game
um he's he is he's a gym rat baseball
player
and he does it absolutely properly and
correct joe it's the
sound off the bat the ball makes the one
two nights ago
it just sounded like a cannon
no lie i'm telling you when he hits him
and they did bring that up we all
brought it up into that guy it was that
loud it's a different sound
it's like an explosion there's there's a
few guys that are able to do that
and he's he's at the top of the list i
guess he said more homeless
450 foot or better this year the other
one that said
463 which i still think is an artificial
number i don't i don't care what they
say
i mean where that thing would eventually
land was beyond that right
i i don't i don't understand this stuff
and they they tell me it's accurate
um i don't always believe everything i
hear so it's it's incredible to watch it
as loud as it gets
yeah the exit velocity too i mean in all
your years in the sport can you
compare that sound to someone else i
mean obviously
mike has done it you know over his
career as well but
yep yeah i mean bonds i mean when i saw
bonds and griffey
uh coming up um you know a-rod could do
that on occasion but
uh i don't know i didn't get i wasn't
with those other guys on a daily basis
like i am with shohei
it's different it's just different the
whole man last night
you know ball a little bit down and away
he just he
literally flicked it and that was a
bullet to write i don't even know what
that was
off the bat velocity uh he's
every time he barrels it up man it is
going to get hit extremely hard
number 37 last night joe where's the
rally monkey
is he uh in a cage behind her desk or is
he
i don't know i mean they've been
bringing out this little uh prairie dog
or chipmunk
starting to yell in the latter innings
um it's almost like a
i think it's a seventh inning kind of a
stretch i'm not even sure the
the reason i remember we brought the
monkey to bear years ago a lot of the
guys couldn't stand it we thought it was
so weird and
awkward and and a lot of times just
gotta wait for corny to become
cool but i don't know if the if the
monkeys really just hold them back
uh i think before the oakland series
bring them back out that starts the
night but
this other little gig they got going on
julie elicits a good response from the
crowd
yeah you know who really really was
annoyed by the rally monkey darren
erstadt
he really was for some reason it really
a lot bothered darren but
really right there right i said it not
you
joe so great to have you we um it was
just and it's fun to be able to talk to
you a little bit
even just a little bit about 2002 it was
lightning in a bottle that six and 14
start and that was really fun so
really enjoying watching you manage now
and have fun i mean how do you not
have fun with this guy absolutely i
agree with you 100
you should regardless of we have show
hey or tony or not we we should all be
very grateful
for the opportunity to work in the major
leagues uh we make it into life and
death and it really should
and truly be fun and games and that's
what we got to really create throughout
the entire industry
both for the players and the fans
watching this and uh
i believe that 100 and you know me so
you know that's true
final point thanks for having me on
today it's always my pleasure it's great
to talk to you again it's been a little
bit too long
all right be well and that's your best
rich too i'll pass it along thanks joe
that's joe madden of these
la angels and i i did put you on the
spot chris
you did i wasn't expecting that because
it's fun to bring you into the
conversation and you are
resident baseball yeah i love baseball i
love
uh watching this kid play every single
night it's
he's doing things we've never seen and i
think any time you get a chance to sit
back and watch whether it's
socially or on tv or at the game in
person
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here